[Music]
we thought we'd check in on the latest
developments in the ongoing Trump
scandals that we've been calling stupid
Watergate a story with all the gravity
of Watergate if during it there was a
gas leak in the White House and Nixon
had been really into huffing glue well
well this week stupid Watergate had
another plot twist thanks to Rudy
Giuliani who only joined Trump's legal
team two weeks ago but on Wednesday made
big news during an appearance on Fox
basically Trump is on record denying
knowing about a $130,000 payment to
stormy Daniels to keep quiet about their
alleged affair but despite that for some
reason Giuliani Trump's lawyer now
remember offered a whole new story about
where the money came from that even
startled Sean Hannity I'm giving you a
fact now that you don't know it's not
campaign money no campaign finance
violation so they funneled it through
the law firm funnel throw of him and the
president repaid it oh I didn't know
that he did yeah there's no campaign
finance law zero zero
he not only contradicting what his
client said he topped it off with the
drunk sounding zero of a man saying my
girlfriend left me but guess how many
this guy gives zero now now in
saying that Giuliani may have just
exposed Trump to multiple new legal and
political problems but he wasn't done
because during his media blitz he also
undercut the White House's official line
on why James Comey was fired prematurely
announced the release of American
hostages from North Korea something that
as of this taping has still not happened
and made this creepy comment about what
would happen if prosecutors targeted
Trump's daughter I think I would get on
get on my charger and go right into the
writers their offices with a lance if
they go after Ivanka thought about her
son-in-law they've talked about him I
guess I Gerald is a fine man you know
that but men are you know disposable but
a fine woman like Ivanka come on
okay setting aside the sleaziness of
calling Ivanka a fine woman let's not
forget that he also just called a living
human being
disposable which is pretty harsh but
also it is Jared you know it's Jared he
is basically a six foot three inch stack
of packing peanuts it's Jared he's
useless now no Giuliani's interview was
so ill-advised and chaotic it left many
people on TV wondering what exactly had
become of him it's a long way from
America's mayor after 9/11 there's
something awful Giuliani yeah this is
not the time absolutely I mean this is
shocking coming from somebody who was
the post 9/11 mayor of New York City
after 9/11 I think Giuliani had a ton of
credibility with the American people
over this past week it seems like that's
kind of all worn off exactly people seem
to be as shocked at finding out who
Giuliani really is as a child at Disney
World who accidentally saw Mickey Mouse
pull off his head to reveal that he was
actually tilda swinton not only are you
not what I thought you are a moment ago
you are terrifying and if any
part of you is also wondering what on
earth happened to Rudy Giuliani tonight
we're going to try and answer that for
you because the short answer is nothing
he's always been this way and I know
that that might be a little jarring to
hear because the thing that he's most
famous for is being mayor of New York
City on 9/11 after which he was rightly
celebrated for being a calm steady
presence he was TIME's Person of the
Year he received an honorary knighthood
from Great Britain and its closest
American equivalent being played in a
made-for-tv movie by mr. James Woods
Democrats always talked about things
getting better Republicans did whatever
they could to make them better
that's what we're here for
[Music]
hot right right I mean come on who
wouldn't want to watch James Woods and
the lady from Kindergarten Cop trade
Republican themes pillow talk on a green
screen beach before exchanging the most
sexless kiss in the history of film how
did that not win all of the awards but
to truly understand Giuliani you have to
go back before 9/11 now he first made a
name for himself as a federal prosecutor
where he had quite a deep and lasting
taste for the limelight performing
stunts like going undercover to buy
crack while dressed in a Hells Angels
vest and a white dress shirt which made
him look less like a street junkie and
more like the third best member of an
all dad blues band called dad to the
bone now he eventually decided to run
for mayor which was somewhat risky at
the time due to some substantial baggage
an internal document produced by his own
campaign flagged a weirdness factor
around him because and this is true his
first marriage was to his second cousin
that's right America's mayor was a cosna
slur but-but-but don't worry don't worry
because he had an excuse for that
Giuliani says they only discovered their
family relation after many years of
marriage Oh didn't think it was
just a little bit weird at the wedding
ceremony when one side of the church was
both families and the other was just one
very nervous photographer who didn't
take a single picture now nevertheless
Giuliani was elected and and as mayor he
continued his love of the cameras
showing up everywhere from the Whoopi
Goldberg movie Eddy to an episode of Law
& Order to Bill Cosby CBS sitcom which
has not dated badly in any shape or form
but what many New Yorkers remember most
about the Giuliani is was his
unrelentingly abrasive personal style
he had a weekly local radio show where
he would take calls from constituents
which should be easy to do you just
listen to their concerns and you
politely disagree whenever necessary but
just listen to this exchange with a
ferret owner annoyed by the city's ban
on owning them as pets there's something
deranged about you you excessive
concern that you have for ferrets is
something you should examine with a
therapist this conversation is over
David thank you this excessive concern
with little weasels is the sickness
that's right
that is the mayor of New York actively
choosing to insult a New Yorker whose
only crime was being a fan of ferrets
and I am sure that when that ferret fan
was given the chance to present his side
without interruption
he was completely reasonable David
thanks for coming on thank you very much
you have in your hands my notes here say
one ferret is named master Linus Van
Pelt
and the other Princess Katie mini mitts
and that's it I hate to say it but
I think I'm on Giuliani side I'm on Team
Giuliani it turns out that ferret
advocates are a lot like ferrets I
thought I'd like them then I saw one and
now I'm not so sure but it went well
beyond picking fights with ferrets
enthusiasts because Giuliani adopted a
famously tough-on-crime stance with a
severely increased police presence and
an aggressive crackdown on so-called
quality of life crimes like panhandling
and jaywalking now this approach
antagonized a lot of people especially
people of color many remember it as a
time when the police were licensed to do
whatever they wanted a criticism even
shared by some former cops we will get a
lot of flack oh you're just doing this
because Giuliani is letting you do this
and in my heart I knew it was true if
police officers were just every single
person I want to stop you I'm gonna
question you I'm gonna frisk you then
the civil rights are gone and that is
pretty chilling because it's not like
it's easy to navigate New York streets
anyway at worst you're trying to get
around 14 Belgian tourists so don't know
how to walk in a city and at
best you might be ambushed by Billy
Eichner and if you are not up on your
Meryl Streep trivia you deserve
everything he's about to give you
now now by the end of Giuliani second
term many New Yorkers were sick of his
at one point he even had to
move out of the mayor's residence and
made accusations of an extramarital
affair which he handled in the worst
possible way
Giuliani told the media in an
extraordinary news conference that he
intended to separate from the first lady
we've grown grown to live independent
and separate lives he'd given no
heads-up to his wife Wow Wow that is
just about the most humiliating way
possible to end a marriage other than
announcing publicly whoopsie i boned my
cousin but but then of course 9/11
happened and all was forgotten because
as America's mayor his reputation was
suddenly solid-gold
and upon leaving office he immediately
cashed in he wrote a book he gave
speeches making as much as $200,000 a
pop and he launched a consulting firm
called Giuliani Partners a name that
sounds a lot like a euphemism for
cousins who oh oh then there
Giuliani partners it was it was love at
first sight at that great grandmother's
funeral
naina always was a matchmaker now he
also became a partner in a law firm and
over the years his firm's represented
clients such as a tobacco company a
private prison company Bank of America
News Corp on Fox News and Purdue Pharma
the company that got in trouble for
supercharging the opioid crisis
basically the condom companies whose
logos you'd expect to see on an as car
driven by a homicidal grizzly bear and
then in 2007 Giuliani lost what was
supposed to be his destiny a campaign
for president which was catastrophic ly
bad he talked non-stop about 9/11 with
some supporters even holding 8 $9 and 11
cents per person fundraiser all of which
triggered this memorable line from been
candidate Joe Biden during a debate Rudy
Giuliani there's three there's only
three things he mentioned in a sentence
and now in a verb in 911 I mean there's
nothing else
now he's right Giuliani could not stop
leveraging 911 for his own ends as
evidenced by his classic children's book
one fish two fish red fish 911 now in
the end his campaign flamed out
spectacularly he did not win a single
state and he went from the front-runner
for the presidency to being out of the
race by January having spent around
fifty million dollars or to end up with
precisely zero delegates or as he would
put it zero
exactly exactly busy
and after that completely humiliating
presidential flop Giuliani ended up
fading from view
eventually washing up in d-list places
like this
[Music]
ENC mark we posted by rudy guiliani
holy that is a steep fall just ten
years after being named time Person of
the Year Giuliani was doing VJ work for
a cable networks editing for television
presentation of Scarface just think
about how crazy that is
that would be like if in ten years from
now Bravo announced a fuckboys of the
90s marathon hosted by Malala yousafzai
how the did that happen what did I
miss
clearly a significant amount of goodwill
has somehow been squandered Wow Wow
after that after that Giuliani fretted
away years as I rent a quote pundit on
cable news saying various awful things
and he didn't truly join Trump's orbit
until January 2017 when he was named
Trump's cybersecurity advisor
now why did Trump give him that job who
knows and maybe it was because Giuliani
had a security consulting business
called Giuliani security and safety
despite seemingly having no real
background in cybersecurity and if he
watched Giuliani for even 10 seconds you
do really get the sense that he tries to
check his email by opening a word doc
and typing hi Google check email thanks
Rudy although the truth is Trump's real
affection for Giuliani probably came
from his willingness during the campaign
to lend his last shreds of credibility
to various amounts of poisonous nonsense
like this if I did one tenth of what
Hillary Clinton did I'd be in jail she
paid people to create violence at his
rallies she sold 20% of our uranium to
Russia I have eight times online since
January in which she's had massive
coughing fits so go online and put down
Hillary Clinton illness take a look at
the videos for yourself now obviously
that is all horseshit but I do agree
with him on one point there you should
definitely go online and visit Hillary
Clinton illness calm and take a look at
the videos because they are i opening
and the reason I know that is we bought
the URL for
automatically redirect to something that
Rudy Rudy Guiliani would hate this
animation of to fair it's
awesome also it is worth noting stop it
also it is worth noting that Giuliani
security and despite Giuliani's
cybersecurity expertise didn't seem to
think to buy the URL Giuliani - security
calm so we now own that as well the only
thing that irritates more than two
ferrets two ferrets or cousins
not I mean the sexual tension
there is unbearable you know each other
so well and when you look at all of this
in total you realize that Giuliani's
role as Trump's lawyer isn't an
aberration everything in his life has
led to this point and while he may well
be providing terrible legal
representation for Trump he's actually
the most honest representation of him in
general because think about it they're
basically two versions of the same
person they're both New Yorkers coasting
on their reputations they both had three
marriages neither of them can shut up
when in front of a camera and perhaps
most importantly they both want to
Ivanka which which is weird for Trump
because Ivanka is in his family and is
weird for Giuliani because she isn't so
what happens what happened to Giuliani
is really not the right question he's
always been like this what's going to
happen to him is more to the point
because he is now the public face of
Trump's legal team and who knows what
he's gonna come up that maybe he Prem's
Trump down through sheer incompetence
maybe he gets fired in the next two
weeks although to be honest at the rate
we're going he is so fatally flawed as a
human being that he's probably going to
end up president although although to do
that he'll need a campaign website which
he might find difficult because for the
record Rudy Giuliani 2020 for calm is no
longer available because we bought it
and it links to a dancing ferret giving
you the thing
you